Wow Chris, that's another really hard order of operations problem. If you got
negative 675, you got the answer right. Now, this was a tough problem, and I
even had to use my calculator. Now, let's see how I got negative 675. When I'm
looking at this problem, once again, I want to work from the inner parenthesis
outwards, following my order of operations. So, the first thing I see is an
innermost paretheses of 1 plus 2, so that's the first operation I'm going to
perform. Again, I want to make sure that I copy down all of the other operations
that I have not yet performed. Now that I've performed the operation in the
inner most parentheses, I can do the next level of parentheses which are these
brackets. So, I want to do negative 4 times 3, which is negative 12. From here,
I see that I have another operation in parentheses which is 4 minus 10. So, I
can evaluate 4 minus 10 which is negative 6. Now that I've performed all the
operations inside parentheses, I can move on to my exponents or my powers. So, I
have three exponents. I have negative 6 squared. Remember when the negative is
inside the parentheses, it's part of the base. So, it's negative 6 times
negative 6 which is 36. 3 squared of course is nine, and negative 12 squared is
144. Now that I've done all my exponents, I can do my multiplication and
division. The only multiplication I have is negative 5 times 144. So, I can
write 36 plus 9, negative 5 times positive 144, I had to get my calculator out
for this one, is negative 720. Now that I've done all my multiplication and
division, I can do my addition and subtraction in order from left to right. So
first thing I have to do is 36 plus 9, which is 45, minus 720. 45 minus 720
gives me the negative 675. Great job.